we are here with oprah winfrey
i'm doing drew i'm doing drew right now
i just
hi gail
yeah she's saying hi she's saying hi
dale i
i just want to say i think that three of
us should get together you know
i'm i think that would be so much fun
yes when this pancake is over let's make
sure that happens drew all right gail
i'll talk to you later
you know we all i think thrive in this
world through friendship
you know a lot of you know children and
marriages they
you know the friends were there at the
beginning
they'll be there till the end they're
these sort of lifelong relationships
it's different than blood family it's
choice but it feels
as intimate and loyal and your
friendship with gail has been something
that
you know we all aspired to because we
want that kind of friendship in our life
and
by the way you now have oprah daily
which i happen to mention to gail
that i thought that the oprah daily the
daily word it's so
brilliant well thank you thank you i
wanted
i i i actually came up with that because
i wanted it to be
what i realized is that the oprah show
was a habit just like the drew barrymore
show
people were creating a habit around that
and that's what you want
that's your core viewer that's who
you're speaking to every day
and the idea of having a
daily inspiration point a daily quote
a daily something that you
can rely on to give you just a little
lift you know my whole goal throughout
my life even before i could articulate
it
is how do you bring a light into
people's lives
how do you let them see the best of
themselves how do you
allow them to grow into becoming more of
who they
are which is what every one of us is
actually aspiring to do whether you can
articulate that for yourself
or not you just you just want to become
more more solid
you want to have the ability to have the
fullest expression of yourself
as a human being and you do that
by by habits by by rituals by
creating a space where you can give back
to yourself in a way that allows you to
flourish so
we are growing it into what
i know will be in the future is a daily
spot of inspiration for everybody so
thank you for mentioning that
we need you on the daily i listened to
your serious xm channel through both my
pregnancies and
i it was it was my daily
north star it was my daily fix thank you
for that
it's true i'll never forget the story
you told about gail getting the water
for the traffic cop and how that
moment was her being such an
important and good parent to her son
because she was showing him
the kind of person to be and that gave
me hope because
i felt so lost like what blueprint do i
have to pull on to become a parent
i was scared out of my mind and i
thought hearing that story
if i can be an example to my kids maybe
i don't have to draw from my past or
even
fight it i can try to be myself
and that can that can
give me hope to be a good parent that
story literally changed my life it was
um
so thank you for that well you know gail
is to date
and she always says well all parents do
then i'll pass i don't know they don't
gail is to date the best model
parent i have ever seen i've never seen
anybody who
was more engaged
more respectful of her children
and when she first had kids you know
because we were best friends in in
met at a television station baltimore
and once she
married and had kids i thought well
there's going to be distance in our
relationship because she's not going to
have time to
you know devote to to our friendship
and it that did not happen but what did
happen
every time she was on the phone with me
and one of her children
entered the room she would stop she
would put the phone down
even if she didn't put the phone down
they would be acknowledged
she was present there for them she would
say mommy's on the phone now with annie
oh
and morning bear he calls kirby bear
morning she there was an acknowledgement
and and and what i would have to say
over the years
a mutual respect and i know we're going
to be talking later about the subject of
what happened to you but one of the
things that dr perry says in this book
is that when children grow up and they
realize that they are not getting
the respect that they deserve
from their parents it changes who they
are
what your kids want and this is actually
true of everybody
they want to know that you are that
you're here that you see me
that you see me and you hear me and that
i matter to you
and that is true for everybody else in
your life too